- [Mark] All right, Loyalty.
- Hi.
- Loyalty, welcome back.
- Thank you for having me back.
- [Mark] So, what's been going on since,
almost two weeks that you were here last?
- I've started to change the way
that I'm doing things.
I've started, ever since I saw you last,
like I started thinking a
lot more about my future
and about what I should be doing now
to get that far, you know?
And I've changed like
my living situations,
I moved to a different area.
- [Mark] So you're still
living on the street?
- Yeah, I'm still on the street.
- Have you-
- I'm still in the tent,
but I just moved locations.
- Yeah.
- I'm not on Skid Row anymore.
I'm like in the thirties now.
I just wanted to move myself a little bit.
I still have my addiction.
So I just wanted to move myself
a little bit farther away
from like the main piece.
So I'm not in so much drama
and so much unnecessary stuff,
you know?
- Yeah, good idea.
Good thinking.
So, I don't know if you've seen your video
or seen the comments on your video,
but there's been quite a bit
of response to your story.
- Really?
- A lot of people
wanna help you out.
A lot of people offered
their homes to you.
They offer jobs, they offer, you know.
- Aw.
- There's some people
that have sent money, which is tricky,
'cause sending money to a fentanyl addict
is not always the best idea.
- Just know that my fentanyl addiction,
I have been taken care
of for the most part.
- [Mark] How's that?
- Like,
I have a really good connection right now.
So I get it for like low prices.
- [Mark] Yeah, but. (laughs)
- So all of my money, I don't, I mean,
I don't really have any money right now.
- You're about to, but-
- I'm hungry, you know?
- [Mark] Yeah, I'll ration
out money to you slowly.
So you don't do anything crazy.
- Thank you.
- But
because you have a drug
addiction, you're gonna do things
to get that money that you
need regardless, right?
- Yeah.
- So giving it
to you makes your life a little bit safer?
- Yeah.
- Until you go
into a rehab or go on Suboxone
or something like that.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] So I mean, your talk last time,
you know, you told us,
that you've done all the
things you needed to do
to get your life together.
You were addicted to heroin
once and you got off it,
and you kind of had a job
and a car and a boyfriend.
- For 11 years.
- [Mark] Yeah, 11 years.
So you did this once before.
Are you in the mindset
to do it again right now?
- Honestly, if I could get off the street
and I can basically get the opportunity
to change my life, because
right now I'm just waiting
for that opportunity, you know?
- [Mark] Well, I think you've
got a lot of opportunities
that you don't realize yet.
One of them is with Monica at
the Patrick Cady foundation
who is in Nashville of all places,
where you're from.
- Oh, wow.
- [Mark] She's currently, she's
recently moved to Nashville.
So that would be one of
the best options for you.
I would think,
if you're willing to go to Nashville
and that could be a great thing.
I'll put you on the phone with her as soon
as we're done here,
but regardless there's all kinds of people
that wanna support you
and help you get your life
together and all that, so.
I'll steer you in the right direction
with all these people that wanna help.
And we'll get you some support,
but I don't wanna support
you just like hanging out
in the street and doing fen.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] That's not what
we're talking about.
So, if you're on board with
getting your life together,
I think we can probably do some things
with my viewers
and the GoFundMe campaign,
that's kind of helping you out.
And then also all the
people in the comments
that have been emailing me as well.
And just, how do I help Loyalty?
How do I help her, how do I help her?
So we can do all that stuff for you.
- Definitely.
- It should be really nice,
right?
I mean, you've been using,
you've been smoking fentanyl,
smoking or injecting?
- Yeah, I smoke.
- Smoking, how long?
- I go through about a
hundred dollars a day.
I'm trying to slowly but surely
eventually stop on my own
like without like a rehab or
anything, because honestly,
it's in your mind, you know,
an addiction is an addiction
in your mind and it's
basically like a habit.
Once you do it for so long,
you do get addicted to it.
Not only emotionally and
mentally, but physically too.
With fentanyl, it's a physical addiction.
My body physically craves it.
I go through these withdrawal stages,
where I will get the shakes, so.
My bowels move without me moving them.
I will throw up.
I cry because my bones hurt so bad.
I can't even get up out of bed
whenever I don't have it, you know.
But it's only like at six hours,
that's whenever it starts,
because at six hours,
that it's already processed
through your body.
At 12 hours, that's
whenever the withdrawal
actually is in full motion.
And with fentanyl, it attacks
your central nervous system
and it, certain
neurotransmitters in your head,
and it's tied to your dopamine.
And what it does is like
this is like your dopamine regularly.
This is it with fentanyl.
It just puts a mask on it, you know?
And it completely replaces
them, certain ones anyway.
So whenever you don't have that, it's like
my body's missing
certain things, you know,
like happiness and my
physical body, you know?
So it's like, it's a lot harder,
than people think, to stop.
You can't just stop like that.
You have to do it slowly.
You have to slowly put
yourself off of it, you know?
- [Mark] And when you quit heroin,
which is similar to fentanyl,
how did you do that?
- I stopped basically because
I had the opportunity to stop.
I had a lot of things going for me,
and my job had drug tested me every week.
We would have to do a drug test.
And if you had anything in your
system, they would fire you.
And I didn't wanna lose my job, you know,
I didn't wanna lose my house,
my boyfriend, my dog,
my cars, I didn't wanna
lose none of that, you know?
I worked my ass off to get that shit,
but it got taken away anyway.
So that's why I started doing it again.
- [Mark] But when you quit,
you did it cold turkey
or you did with Suboxone
or something like that?
- I did it with, I can't
think of the name right now.
- Methadone?
- Yeah.
Methadone, I use methadone,
that got me off of it.
And then I stopped using methadone
after a couple weeks, you know?
So I never went back, you know,
after the third time that I
had went, I didn't go back.
So I got off of that as well,
because methadone you can
actually get addicted to too.
- [Mark] Yeah.
What would you like to do with your life?
If you've got everything straightened out?
- I want my happiness back.
Sadly I don't think, I
can my relationship back.
I don't think I can get my dog back.
I don't think I can get
my cars or my house back,
but I should.
It's healthy, it's something,
not to replace it
but better than that, you know?
- [Mark] You're very young yet.
So you'll have other
cars and houses and dogs.
- Right.
- And I'll bet
you'll have other relationships too,
but your health, mental
health, physical health,
all that stuff that
you're lacking right now,
is what's most important.
Because once you get that,
then all the other stuff
will fall into place,
but you won't have any
of the other things,
you maybe get a dog, but that's about it.
And you'll have nothing
else and you'll be stuck
in this life like a lot of
the people you see here,
they're down here for decades.
- Yeah.
- And you're new here.
You've been only down here how long?
- I've been here, in LA?
- [Mark] Well, on Skid Row.
- On Skid Row-
- You're pretty new, right?
- About nine months,
right when COVID-19 happened.
- [Mark] When you lost your job?
That's when you lost your
house and everything else?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Well, I'm sure
myself and a lot of viewers
would love to see you
kind of make some moves
to get your life straight.
So I'll set you up with
some people that have said
they wanna help you
and we'll see how serious they are.
- Okay.
- [Mark] I'll put you on the phone
with Monica and we'll see,
how you guys get along.
And hopefully we get you some support
to get you out of this, the SoHo.
What do you think of Skid Row?
It's treacherous, right?
- Definitely.
Definitely one of the
worst places you could be.
- [Mark] Yeah.
Yeah, it's horrible, and for a young girl,
a young white girls especially,
I think it's really dangerous.
I'm sure you've seen some
of that stuff already.
- Yeah.
- Sounds like.
So what are you doing now
to get money for fentanyl
and food and whatever else?
- Well, on the streets,
especially on Skid Row,
it's a lot easier to get drugs
than food or shelter or any of that.
I don't really,
I'm not,
I don't really wanna talk
about that, you know.
- Understood.
- It's like-
- I won't make you.
- It's kind of sad.
It's kind of depressing,
very personal.
- [Mark] Yeah, I understand.
I won't cry.
Hopefully this will be a chapter
in your life that just kind of,
you put behind you and you move on.
- Hopefully.
- And hopefully
you never come back to a
situation like this ever again.
- [Loyalty] Definitely not.
- [Mark] 'Cause even with COVID,
you could still probably
do some things to get
your life straight and get even get a job.
You can do a lot of great things
despite all these obstacles that we have.
All right then.
I wish you the best of luck here,
and we'll see what we
can do to help you out.
- [Loyalty] Thank you.
- [Mark] All right.
Okay.